you
each latin noun had many different forms
the accusative singular became the basic
form vulgar latin Muru meant wall casa
meant house solid meant salt and art
event
art every latin noun belonged to one of
three categories masculine feminine and
neuter these categories are called
genders but they don't necessarily
correspond to physical gender many words
for inanimate objects were masculine or
feminine and some words for people were
actually neuter romance content words
have a stem and an ending here who and
aunt are endings masculine or neuter ooh
feminine ah any gender can end in a
vulgar latin combined masculine and
neuter ooh
into a single masculine gender
so masculine Moodle and neuter variable
both become masculine in the romance
languages Casa is feminine solace stays
masculine and artist is feminine in
Mediterranean Romance languages
masculine nouns and in all or
these are the modern languages Spanish
Moodle Sardinian Moodle the italian
mauro portuguese moto from late latin
guru
in eastern Spain France Switzerland
northern Italy and Romania this
masculine and he actually wears off so
we get French move Romanian food romance
meat you can see that the original
ending has been lost feminine nouns in
aa keep that behind Iberia Italy
southern France and Switzerland
so Petra becomes Spanish Piedra Italian
Pietra Sardinian pedra feminine gets
weaker in Catalan Romanian and
Portuguese pedra Piatra it has a sound
like ah instead of a French eventually
just loses this feminine ah
Pierre
final a also gets weaker outside of
Italy so we have Italian at the camp
attorneys Sardinia RT but romance art or
French F or Italian salad but Spanish
Sun French cell
neuters remain in romanian and a few
curious cases in Italian and Romansh
Romanian neuters have a masculine
looking form in the singular but
feminine like forms in the plural so
neuter vet abou becomes Romanian Viterbo
but the plural is vet abhi
there's an east-west split in the way
Romance languages turn basic nouns like
Moodle into plurals Western Romance
languages like French Spanish oxygen
Portuguese and Sardinian add an S to the
end this comes from the accusative
plural in Latin
Moodle has the accusative plural muros
which you can see in the Sardinian
morose
Spanish morose catalan Morse and French
meal
similarly the accusative plural of Casa
is cassettes so Spanish Casas Catalan
Casas and so on
Eastern Romance languages lean on the
nominative plural instead which is
responsible for all those academic
sounding Latin plurals in English
alumnus alumni alumni alumni those are
the same plurals that survive in Eastern
Romance languages like Italian Sicilian
and Romanian Moodle has the plural Moody
just as Italian mudo becomes Moody and
Romanian mood has the plural mood
at a glance it looks like Eastern
romance also owes its feminine plurals
to the Latin nominative Latin Casa has a
nominative plural Casa which should
become romance kasi but evidence points
to an accusative origin eastern romance
lost final essence so Casas eventually
changed to Italian Kazi and Romanian
gossip what about the plurals of those
nouns ending in egg nouns in the West
still add s so we have Brazilian
Portuguese Archie and Archie's those
vowel switching Eastern nouns turn that
a to an e Aden Artie that's all for the
basics of masculine feminine and neuter
gender and singular and plural number of
nouns in the romance languages
you